that's what I said that's what I said  earlier though you would only date a  broke guy if you thought he could make  money later yeah you would never date a  broke guy that you knew was going to be  broke okay but okay wait you know what  guys I don't think they're too  correlates wait and and you just said  it's easier to to make money  no I said it I said it's easier to lose  weight than it is to make money okay  okay  since you're saying that it's different  would you marry a man who is obese would  I marry a man would you marry a man  who's obese if I love him yeah but what  does that mean what would it take for  you to love him  I I would not I would not all right